a rogue star is headed straight for our
sun
if these two stars slam into each other
it could spell the end of all life on
our planet
how could a rogue star end up in our
solar system
what would this epic collision look like
and how much time do you have to live
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a rogue star collided with the
sun
as the name would suggest rogue stars
drift through space
they don't belong to any particular
galaxy or if they once did they've been
ejected from their homes at some point
by supernovas or two galaxies ramming
into each other
whatever it is that sends these stars
hurtling away from the gravitational
pull of their original galaxies it fires
them off at very high speeds
in order to break free of our own milky
way galaxy a star would need to move as
fast as
550 kilometers per second
luckily our sun is only moving at a mere
200 kilometers per second
not nearly fast enough to become rogue
but these wandering stars aren't all
that uncommon
they may even account for as many as
half of the 200 billion trillion stars
in the universe
and one of them could be headed toward
our sun right now
meet glees 710
this rogue dwarf star is on a trajectory
that would bring it close to our solar
system in around 1.3 million years
when gliese 710 eventually reaches us it
would enter the outermost section of our
solar system the oort cloud at a speed
of about 51
500 kilometers per hour
it could send the icy bodies out there
flying in different directions
maybe even right toward earth once it
has reached neptune the countdown to the
epic collision would begin
t minus 10 years till the impact with
the sun
at this point you'd better just plan to
live your best life while preparing for
the upcoming apocalypse
the gravitational pull of gliese 710
would destabilize the orbits of our
planetary neighbors nudging them left
and right
this could go as far as pushing earth
out of the habitable zone
or it could turn us into a rogue planet
after
unceremoniously being catapulted out of
the solar system
after 10 years it would finally be
getting close to collision time
as each day passes
things are only going to get worse
one possibility is that the sun and
gliese 710 would merge into a red nova
this would result in a violent explosion
that would unleash nearly half a million
times more light than what the sun does
right now
given the amount of time light takes to
travel from the sun to the earth you
would be blissfully unaware of this
destructive explosion for eight minutes
but the moment you do find out all that
light would likely blind you in a
millisecond and then immediately fry you
on the spot
that's because directly behind this
blinding light would be super hot gas
this wave of heat could be powerful
enough to wipe out nearly everything in
its path
bye bye mercury venus and
yeah earth 2
our atmosphere and oceans would be
completely blasted away
this would leave our planet as nothing
more than a barren rock
the explosion would also have created
massive amounts of high energetic
neutrinos
these would be able to boil you from the
inside out
earth would also be shrouded in lethal
levels of uv and gamma radiation
even if you somehow managed to survive
the explosion
you wouldn't last long from the harmful
effects of all this radiation
you'd have damage to your eyes skin and
even dna
now if an alien species was watching
this all unfold from a distant galaxy
with an incredibly powerful telescope
they'd see a single bright star
surrounded by an excess of reddish
colored gas
and the infrared light left behind from
the explosion would be visible for a
long time after
but that wouldn't be the only way all
this could possibly go down
there is a possibility there could be a
more peaceful alternative
yeah if the two stars are moving a bit
slower relative to each other they could
end up merging into one massive new star
as they orbit each other
our sun would strip mass from its
smaller companion gliese 710
and swallow it in a process known as
stellar cannibalism
then this extremely hot and bright star
would be called a blue straggler
though it may sound many times more
peaceful
this option would still likely spell out
the end of life on earth
with our sun now a massive blue star
the habitable zone of our solar system
would be pushed further away
what else would happen if our sun became
a blue star
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]